oh there's nothing really crazy bad I
walk around and they may take a foot of
your dog I take a photo of your dog I
take a photo of your dog say okay okay
good luck trying to get his photo sit
squeak toy comes out I start making a
weird noise one second later the dog is
posing like a professional very nice
gonna give you card I take photos of
dogs oh you're the dog is she
I ask people sometimes if you had all
the money in the world what would you do
fight all the money I'd probably travel
with my camera in hand with dogs I'm
doing it in the beginning of the project
no one knew who I was I was just walking
around every day and having these
interactions with dogs and made me feel
good about being sort of unemployed just
you know screw people just I just want
to handle the dogs but he has a projects
grown everything I've become this sort
of figure so here get the image queued
up got the caption and host at this
point it's 500 likes per minute
something like that there's a lot of
activity it's still baffling to me how
many people like each of these photos I
put out I haven't done any outreach I
haven't paid for any advertising it's
something people want and need
[Music]
oh very nice
Georgia come a Boston Terrier kind of
six months old it's a beautiful sight
for dog photographer New York is a
special place to be a documentary Street
Fighter
I can't really imagine doing this blog
anywhere else every night the city has
its canine personalities in each of the
neighborhoods I would shoot downtown
weekends are the best because you get
owners walking their dogs during the day
versus the walkers with five of the dogs
such a park has great dogs that free
sign is a lot of poodle exotic breeds
Brooklyn has more pitbulls cut it out
any time doesn't have any dogs
[Music]
there's a lot of visual noise given that
tree contacts what what are you three
but I shoot pretty shallow
depth-of-field I like to isolate this
sort of moment in time for this dog in
its life
the dog they're not posing for a picture
they're sitting for the ball we're
sitting to the tree it's my challenge to
make them seem like there's something
dramatic happening I guess what it is is
personifying the dog and making them
seem like person that's where the to me
that the humor is I don't feature their
faces but when there's something
interesting about the owners I like to
shoot a little wider and include their
lower half because it's a lot to glean
from that relationship who are these
guys hopefully you're doing it so thank
you everyone about you awesome I think
we gotta get one I don't have a dog
right now
you know how the girlfriend I don't work
with people in the same way that most
people do and I sometimes feel that sort
of loneliness I come home and I'm like
talking to my rug but I do connect with
people through their dogs I think you
know don't my own dog dogs have opened
up a whole world for me that's made me
less lonely
I think I should have just an innate
human emotions to want to love and to
want to give up and dogs have that in
abundance I've only been doing this for
two years but I do feel more so
spiritually aligned dogs don't need that
much to be happy they need food and love
right that's something I've always
aspired to do is to take a page either
book become more is simple in the way I
look the world
you
[Music]